[Music]
and violent kidnapping news submitted by
thug life thug lie to pucks alive what
are my glasses oh yeah oh yeah yeah I
don't have the joint on these oh the
joint has to fly your [ __ ] editors
you do it three suspects are in custody
for the kidnapping and torture of two
actors in Los Angeles in Los Angeles we
can tell one more time who did what dude
they're just random people and like
there are three suspects three suspects
in custody for kidnapping torturing to
hackers they kidnap from Chili's and
yeah it wasn't heating right this is
true that's why she said it no that's
why we have traffic in LA because
everyone's like an actor
Danny's job some [ __ ] why isn't it me
what steve says it it's either a cure oh
I see it I don't know my intonation is
because sometimes I come off as intense
and I don't even know that I'm being
intense I'm like why is everyone
reacting to me this way I was just
saying something like that's a girl
problem it is yeah the tone problem yeah
oh how to keep that on control anyway
wish there was a pill for that yeah
tonal film take some tonal feel and
relax
you don't really wish that that was a
thing it would solve so many of my
marital problems yeah what joy at home
where's the tea yet
all right bamboos ever talking about
here it's uh it's an actor named Joseph
Capone who didn't find any photos of and
nothing no there's not a [ __ ] actor
if he's not on IMDB Niki anybody could
be on IMDB you get that thought come on
I am DB but my pictures not on I think
Sam you know it's funny so like I think
we're all are but everything that's on
there for me is like totally incorrect
I'm like I was never an insider edition
oh yeah I mean that's cool there's ten
Steve greens on IMDB all of them are me
I'm kidding ten separate Steve yeah but
they're all me and there's one that most
of my stuff on there but there's like
every other thing has a lot of my I've
tried for years it's impossible weird so
that's there's only one Nicky Lima Nicky
limousine good one part I heard it from
someone I liked that it was a [ __ ] I
like that so that was the actor right
and then that the other person that got
kidnapped is an actress named Daisy
McCracken she's in like a direct-to-dvd
purge movie know what's crackin
McCracken so she was in Halloween
resurrection this is Daisy McCracken
that's the new one that's coming up
right actually oh never mind that's
going on every panel looks like um like
a Heather Graham mixed with um I should
only have it right well what's her name
yeah you know I'm talking about
from stellar and also what's-her-name
from your favorite movie Big Lebowski
like what you doing anymore
yeah Julianne Moore oh yeah don't listen
to the anymore to Thurman yeah she's my
she's a McCracken
I just think about Homer Thurmond was so
[ __ ] high really oh she's your friend
and now you know I live in spirit I
haven't seen her in a while
that's it Oh or did you not see Batman
Robin forget about it to me she looks
like a boy with long hair alright okay
so they so three suspects let me tell
you guys the sir this is the fool I
wanna [ __ ] Britney Spears with her no
way you're [ __ ] toxic oh yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah play for you yeah I love that
one
oh you see Joe we all want to [ __ ] but
yeah dude I have so much fun with her
you're not I didn't want a [ __ ]
I got shut down syndrom eyes so you know
I realized I had my taste change
throughout in life
so before I thought I thought Britney
Spears and Anne Hathaway had Down
syndrome eyes
but later on I thought unhappily got
prettier and uh Brokeback Mountain well
she doesn't want you now yeah but then
you can't you don't deserve her my
tastes changed cuz I thought she had
down I thought her and Britney Spears
both had brought down syndrom eyes brown
sent you guys so three suspects no named
Keith who's 33 Jonte was 27 haunte amber
is 26 with all these names yeah so all
three of them went to McCracken's home
[Applause]
that's a good chance name oh and if you
want to say McCracken you have to say in
the traditional Irish and so they
kidnapped her I make fun of my people
man please yes I am McQueen we all don't
need them in the digitus words of my
people please all right so we kidnap
Daisy and Joseph and
apparently they left Joseph in the
bathtub naked without food for 30 hours
while Daisy was going around to
different ATMs trying to get ransom
money and apparently there was a warm
water in the bathtub I don't know if
there was water 24 or 30 hours they took
him to a home in Compton and that's
where he was oh wow
these suspects were they had Daisy drive
around I heard 2011 red lights Lexus oh
[ __ ] what I have to say that kind of car
I don't know but it's in there and I'm
giving you the information I have
because you want to let you know they're
not hurting the ecosystem while they're
doing this whole cube not good brand
deal during this Oh that'd be tight it's
like highlighted the Prius you can click
on it's like a person's car was Alexis
yeah hybrid so what they ended up what
you gonna get robbed get robbed in style
Lexus got a gun on your head want to
drive what comfort Lexus if you have a
gun on your head
make sure have leather seats while
you're driving around a PR motion yeah
so they were they were trying to get her
to pay a ransom of either 10,000 or
20,000 that's how they report it I don't
know why but they're like you have a
choice yes 10,000 or 20,000 I'll choose
each a thousand make a choice I don't
have 20 can I give you 10 right it's
like 20 we're gonna brick what's the
scope of work right 10 oh man you're
actually like pretty close so apparently
we did meme him main man means it could
cut off of them or they somehow major
injured destroyed
that's a there's some reports saying I
bought like
but then there's other reports saying
like unknown body parts oh I don't
really know that sucks
there I've been getting to me it's gonna
be pretty obvious if it's as I I won't
be unknown yeah if he's walking around
with the eye patch you know he doesn't
have a pirate yes he's alive
getting maimed that's the worst part of
the bank oh he's not prepared for not
trying to be a [ __ ] cat if you see
this guy's the iPad you know he's not in
the new Pirates of Caribbean let's say
that yeah that's why I wanna die in
Apocalypse I don't want to be maimed and
you know what maybe your good person
what no you don't know that they made me
for food they'll mean you for for food
what country do you live in
no one apocalypse they said let me tell
you okay tell me
so they were casing these two out could
they would they had to and that's that's
kind of smart because it's like who's
looking for you're not that smart
they're really done so what they ended
up doing is they had Daisy write them a
$10,000 check oh because they couldn't
get money from these what they cashed in
their own bank accounts that's amazing
and then they also had easy like sign
off her Lexus to the girl remember like
oh yeah now you own this car but so
stupid so they took her back to her -
Daisy's home let's get more paper trail
and then she somehow escaped and then
that's how she was able to call the cops
and then they ended up people so other
than the maiming which is horrible what
other torture happened well in the
bathtub it was mainly Joseph that
they're reporting that he was the one
mainly tortured but why was he getting
tortured if he wasn't in charge with
money
oh I guess maybe yeah motivation to get
her to get money so he was her boyfriend
and I don't know they don't what if
she's like I don't give a [ __ ] about
that full right what if they broke up
after that I don't know so you guys want
to hear all these charges there's a lot
of girls here so
so Stuart Keith the 33 year old he had
four prior convictions for first-degree
burglary between 2011 and 2013
he's charged with one count each of
kidnapping for ransom kidnapping and
kidnapping to commit another crime that
he's now getting all first-degree wait
wait wait did you say there's a charge
for mayhem mayhem
oh no the g2 anything each other was
three three different charges two
first-degree residential burglary
assault with the semi-automatic firearm
assault all because he pistol whipped
Joseph Joseph Capone assault with the
firearm and possession for sale of
methamphetamine along with two counts
each of conspiracy to commit a crime
crime and possession of a firearm by a
felony decorated criminal
Jonte the 27 year old he was charged
with one count each of kidnapping for
ransom kidnapping condemned me to commit
another crime first-degree residential
burglary unlawful driving or taking of a
vehicle perjury by declaration forgery
grand theft auto possession for sale of
methamphetamine and resisting
obstructing or delaying a peace officer
or EMT along with two counts of
conspiracy to commit a crime and then
the girl amber is charged with six
counts one count each of kidnapping to
commit another crime perjury by
declaration forgery and grand theft auto
as well as two counts of conspiracy to
commit a crime and so when they found
and apparently she got arrested and then
they let her go for some weird reason so
they gave me info beau the other ones
maybe but then the cops ended up
arresting her one morning and witnesses
saw this arrest and it went viral so I'm
gonna show you guys the video that they
took of this girl getting we don't
record we don't like the commentary
because these people obviously didn't
know what she did they thought she was
just an innocent really I'm getting
pulled over by all these cops but they
don't know the hosts dog
[Music]
I'm like thank you cops cuz you just
don't know if she's gonna kidnap you
she's gonna pull some [ __ ] you don't
name somebody welcome to a world where
people watch a documentary about
something and they think they know
everything but I know cuz if I was if I
was in her shoes right and I knew that
the cops were after me
I [ __ ] try to do everything I can to
get away I'd [ __ ] shoot I [ __ ]
drive away I'll [ __ ] stop the car
pretend like I'm gonna stop and I'm
[ __ ] oh I love that movie that's a
good move that always gets the extra 15
seconds yeah so that LAPD had to respond
on their own Twitter to that Twitter
thing or a video and they were saying
like this woman was involved in a
violent kidnapping and now she's being
held on a 1 million dollar bail extra
one she's just a sweet little lady hair
on just by the other girl signing over
her car she's like whoa now I got a
Lexus and like you think that it's like
she'll get her Lexus bag you idiot
stupid how could you be so [ __ ] state
but guys she's a plug-in dumb they
accept that a check any accepted that a
[ __ ] pink slip
thankfully she's they're still alive man
thankfully so is there any info on how
they got kidnapped like if they grabbed
him and threw him in the car or you do
dicken after
at her home that's it damn Galina
[Music]